- One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
- Wow.
- Thanks.
- That's actually good, yeah.
("Desi Way")
Namaste, my name is Aba
and I've been learning Bharatanatyam
for the past 20 years now.
It's been fun learning and understanding
this beautiful dance form,
and also teaching a little.
- I think it needs flexibility.
- With your eyes, you have to do this.
- I really hope the
woman doesn't yell at me.
- When you start with Bharatanatyam,
you have to start with the Namaskar.
Right, then left, then you go
down, and then to your eyes,
and then you come back up.
Okay, just come back up.
Oh my god, you can't
come back up, can you?
(laughing)
- Sorry. I'm sorry.
- Okay.
- This is why you don't skip leg day.
- Hand gestures is
this, is this, no, this.
Oh, okay, this is not
how you sit, like this.
Okay, so, one, left.
You're still sitting like that.
One, two, one, no, no, no, not that fast.
- You do the neck thingy
and you do the half thingy
and you do your facial expressions
and do the three patakas
together at the same time?
- Yes, it is something that
any human being can manage.
- Right.
- One, two, that extra
head bob is not something
that I asked for, did I?
Open, close.
(speaks in foreign language)
- I'm just so good at this.
- Continue.
So we're gonna do a piece
on Krishna and Radha.
So you're Krishna, of course.
Okay, so, you're Radha.
- I'm Radha.
- And she's Krishna.
Radha is actually in the jungle
and she is waiting for
Krishna and Krishna is late.
One, two, see the creeper to the side.
But where is Krishna?
And then she sees that he's, whatever,
playing garba with other women.
Upon seeing that, she is
furious and she leaves.
When she sees you, you ask
your friends to go away.
- Friends.
- And now you see-- yeah, you seen him
and then you walk away.
And then Krishna is
going to try really hard
to win her over.
And you're like, I'm really s--
- Babe, why you do this?
Babe, please.
- It's like how you--
- Oh, yeah, like you--
- School, school, yeah, okay.
- The very scope of the
dance is mind-blowing.
- So I thought it was a really girly thing
and turns out, it's an art like that.
- A lot of people think
that guys can't dance,
or guys can't do classical Indian dances,
but that's untrue.
We're just gonna do the Namaskar together.
("Desi Way")